[Music]
this is the Drake Equation first
presented in 1961 by dr. Frank Drake an
astronomer at the National Radio
Astronomy Observatory in Green Bank West
Virginia where in n equals the number of
civilizations in the Milky Way galaxy
whose electromagnetic emissions are
detectable are equals the rate of
formation of stars suitable for the
development of intelligent life F P
equals the fraction of those stars with
planetary systems an e equals the number
of planets per solar system with an
environment suitable for life FL equals
the fraction of suitable planets on
which life actually appears AF I equals
the fraction of life-bearing planets on
which intelligent life emerges F C
equals the fraction of civilizations
that develop a technology that releases
detectable signs of their existence into
space l equals the length of time such
civilizations release detectable signals
into space got all that since 1961
scientists have used the Drake Equation
to stimulate thinking about finding life
elsewhere in the universe in the words
of one of our greatest cosmological
minds are we alone how how common is
this thing called life this thing called
intelligence where did we come from
what are the possible fates of
intelligent beings to need we
necessarily destroy ourselves might
there be a bright and very long future
for the human species we tend to have
such a narrow view of our place in space
and in time and the the prospect of of
making contact with extraterrestrial
intelligence works too deep provincial
eyes our worldview and I think for that
reason the search itself even without a
success as great merit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I share just a couple things from my
spaceflight experience that might apply
to this I was blessed to live and work
in space for 104 days had the
opportunity to look out the window and
see earth and this just overwhelmingly
impressive way it certainly is a
life-changing experience and I get asked
a lot did I did I see aliens while I was
in space there you know it's kind of
like the bathroom question you're gonna
get that and you know did you see aliens
and I can say not that I know of but I'm
interested in our panel session tonight
because I'd like to think you know as
Earthlings what do we have to look
forward to out in this universe when we
consider life and other places and does
it always have to be life that's with
respect to us to what we consider to be
life and intelligence so I'm looking
forward to introducing our panelists and
getting into this our first participant
is the director of the Carl Sagan
Institute and a professor in astronomy
at Cornell University her research
focuses on modeling new worlds and how
to spot signs of life please welcome
Lisa Colton Eggar
[Applause]
[Laughter]
also joining us is director of
astrobiology at Columbia University and
a global science coordinator for the
earth life science Institute's origins
Network at the Tokyo Institute for
technology please welcome Caleb Scharf
is a distinguished scholar at the
Library of Congress and the director of
the AI mind and society group at the
University of Connecticut a philosopher
and cognitive scientist please welcome
Susan Schneider and our final
participant tonight researches the
origin of life and how to discover it on
other worlds she is an assistant
professor in the school of Earth and
space exploration at Arizona State
University please welcome Sarah Walker
so before we can talk about finding
alien life we need to start with a clear
operating different definition of what
life is about what your definition of
life would be and I think we'll just go
in this case we'll just go right down
the line here so I think I'm gonna start
out by being a little bit cheeky because
I'm an astronomer so I don't have to
give you the real definition of what
life is and most of my biology
colleagues actually tell me I'll know it
when I see it so good luck with that
because the other stars are very far
away but we're working on it so to me
what's really important is there's
something that I can spot in the air of
another planet in the atmosphere like we
have oxygen in our own planet for
example is there something that I can
spot that life does that modifies a
planet its environment enough so I can
actually pick that up by looking at that
planets with my big telescope and so
that definition encompasses a huge
amount of life all the life that changes
the signature gases in the air often of
the world and Carl Sagan looked at our
world and what he saw was the
combination of oxygen with a reducing
gas like methane
and that's a telltale sign for a nice
warm world like ours that life's
happening right there and so that's what
I use but if anybody comes up with a
better definition of other gases I can
look for I'd be more than happy to pass
this along yeah so I mean defining life
is one of those questions I think as
scientists we all know that you'll get a
hundred different answers or you'll get
a kind of blank stares so I'm going to
be a little cheeky as well and perhaps a
little contrary and say that you know in
some ways I think it may be the wrong
question right now and there are a few
reasons for that part of the reason is
quite simple and it's just that it's
clear that what we consider to be life
is actually a confluence of multiple
phenomena in different ratios depending
on what you're talking about that makes
it extremely complicated a question but
I'll say two other things that I think
make it a difficult question right now
and the first is that when we think
about life we think about life here in
this room in this audience on the bottom
of your shoe whatever that has evolved
after four billion years it's the
product of four billion years of
evolution and that may be different than
whatever happened four billion years ago
it may be very different to what was the
first thing or first system that we
might associate with life then the other
point I want to bring up is I think we
can't quite answer that question yet
because we don't know and I think maybe
some of the other panel members may have
some insight to this whether you can
build life out of other stuff so whether
life can be substrate independent or
more Universal than we think about not
necessarily building out of silicon or
anything like that but building life in
software if you could do that it would
suggest that life is something that can
happen when you have components that can
build enough complexity for it to for it
to sort of emerge
so that's my contrary and answer that we
can't quite answer that question of
defining life yet okay so that's really
nice I'm a philosopher so definitions
are always a train wreck the worry here
is that if you define life in terms of
life as we know it on earth all cases of
life that we know are related so we've
got one instance that we know about and
so if we make a definition based on that
instance and we go look for life
somewhere else it may be that we fail to
detect life because we've narrowed our
definition so much that we are just the
tip of the iceberg there are all sorts
of intriguing cases of life so I agree
with both of you you know to not use a
very constrained definition NASA's
astrobiology Institute has an intriguing
definition which I sometimes defer to
which is a self-sustaining chemical
system capable of Darwinian evolution I
like that but then I kind of think again
as a philosopher wait a second what if a
is self-sustaining and has all sorts of
intriguing properties but the instance
that we have is created by intelligent
design that is we are the designers we
make the AI systems and it doesn't
evolve in a Darwinian fashion so I'm
still not a hundred percent behind the
NASA definition either so I think one of
the problems that we often encounter is
assuming that life is a chemical
phenomena and I think there's a
confusion between the scale at which
life emerges which is probably chemical
and the definition of life which is
likely not related to chemistry
necessarily and could apply to AI so I
liked that Lisa brought up the top that
I know it when I see it you hear there's
so much in the astrobiology community
and and I always kind of like make this
joke about that like if if I know it
when I see it I feel very alive and so
you guys are observing me right now I
guess I'm alive because you know it and
when you see
like if nobody's observing me am I still
alive seem like a very good objective
criteria for science so I think one of
the the problems that we face as
astrobiologists is that our definitions
are really premature because we don't
actually have a theory for life and so
what I mean by that is I the way I think
about living systems is really trying to
understand what is life at a fundamental
level and a lot of our descriptions are
kind of at this very high level where
we're talking about life being
reproducing or about
compartmentalization or metabolism or
chemical self-sustaining system and
those are probably attributes of life
but not really the core property of life
the property that would be universal in
the sense that Caleb was talking about
and if we think about what life is doing
that's very unique in my mind it's it's
it's information processing capability
and that we don't really see any other
kind of systems that use information in
the way that biology does and I think AI
is an excellent example of that DNA in
your cells and how that information gets
read out and actually controls the
function of your cells is another
example and to that point if we start
thinking about these sort of more
abstract ways of thinking about life in
terms of information and the way
information interacts with the physical
world as being a way of quantifying life
suddenly life is not this black or white
yes this is alive no this is not alive
but we could actually derive measurable
criteria for life and that there's
actually a spectrum of living things and
so AI might fall on that spectrum
chemical systems might fall on that
spectrum but so might cities and
multicellular organisms or unicellular
organisms and so I think one of the
challenges for astrobiologists moving
forward is really to challenge ourselves
to think outside the box about what life
is and what the underlying laws might be
of life and whether there are principles
that are really universal well I like
the way go ahead I think one of the
things like a complete again this is
where you get that full scientific
insight that we just like talk and
discuss then it's fun and then we're
trying to come up with something is this
search now we have going now on the
thousands of other worlds that we've
found and detected does need some kind
of definitions that we figure out what
we can spot or what we could look for
however what we do is we keep our eyes
open for weird stuff weird stuff that we
can explain geologically right and then
we'll take that and say look because we
have this one case earth and ours is
amazing it has a wide range of life when
we look at it however it could be
completely different somewhere else but
we'll only get that when we look
somewhere else as we are now doing and
we're trying to also recreate life in
the lab that's like what a lot of our
biologist colleagues are trying to work
out now and if that would work out then
we could change the chemical mix but
right now it's basically a two pong to
approach I would say looking out and
trying to figure out what we can find
and what makes no sense so it's usually
the fun in science the arica moment was
like oh my god this is nothing I would
have ever expected that's what we really
like in a way we don't know what to do
after but that's where it becomes fun
and the other thing is like people
trying to do this theoretically and
trying to do it practically in the lab
from the most basic chemical compounds
and I think it's really really cool to
be alive right now
because for 2,000 years a little bit
more people were asking whether we alone
in the universe and we are so close to
figuring that lead into part two which
is finding life since 1992 more than
3,500 exoplanets have been found
orbiting stars other than our Sun and
60% of these are rocky planets not
unlike ours so Lisa let's start with you
in the opening film we heard from Carl
Sagan himself about the value of
searching for life out there in the
stars as director of the Sagan Institute
can you tell us how that search is going
I mean there's a lot of things going on
so thing one of the most fascinating
things for me if you were saying about
25 years ago this whole thing is like
you know there are other planets out
other worlds required a bottle of wine
and a lot of different opinions right
now we found nearly 4000 worlds orbiting
other stars alien Suns so when you look
up in the sky doesn't work in Manhattan
but works once the outside
I tried yesterday I could find two stars
when you out and you actually well one
thing that works in Manhattan if you out
and you look at the sky and you count
one two
one out of two stars or one out of two
suns that you see in the night sky has a
planet and one out of five has a planet
that could be like ours and what that
means is that it's small enough to be a
rock and at the right distance from this
hot star where it's not too hot and not
too close so you could have liquid water
one out of five and we have two hundred
billion stars in our Milky Way our
galaxy alone
so if you do the math we have 40 billion
interesting places to look and we have
no idea whether there is life out there
because we had only half the telescope's
yet that are big enough to actually
catch the light from this planets to
check however rebuilding those and the
first one is gonna launch in two years
it's the chain's Webb Space Telescope
and that one at the edge of the
technical possibility will have the
capability to spot these gases life
produces in the air of other worlds that
could be like ours so the search is
going well so far I like our off I have
no answer and a good answer actually if
anybody ever asks you when you come out
of this panel for example what the
chances are that there's life out there
in the universe a good friend of mine
one of the discoverer of the first
exoplanets michelle maher always says
50% plus minus 50
I think it's a way to put it that's
awesome and we know there are a lot of
other missions that are happening as
well I hope you'll get a chance to
discuss some of them too
Caleb when when you think about this
what are the parameters for looking for
life on these exoplanets one of the
things I'm very interested in with my
colleagues is understanding even
something as fundamental as the nature
of climate you mentioned the idea of the
planet needing to be just at the right
distance from its parent star where it's
not too hot not too cold
Goldilocks so whatever you want to call
it but that itself is actually a very
complex problem as you well know so for
example we're trying to take
supercomputer simulations of planetary
climate and mortal alien worlds and find
out what happens when you change the day
length of a planet what happens when you
change the tilt of a planet what happens
when you change the shape of the orbit
what happens when you change the gravity
of a planet and so on and it turns out
to be a difficult problem just answer
whether or not the surface environment
of a planet may be temperate which is
kind of one of our methods of selecting
out candidate planets for then trying to
probe deeper with these these great new
telescopes looking for chemical
signatures and so on you kind of need to
know the thermal environment the climate
environment so I can give you an example
of what happens when you slow a planet
like the earth down you might think what
how does that change climate well it
actually completely alters the
circulation patterns of the atmosphere
on a planet and our models contain
oceans and atmospheres and chemistry and
salt and we're finding that you change
the rotation rate of a planet you
actually warm up the poles and you cool
down the equator but you also do other
things if the planet has water it begins
to build certain patterns of cloud that
play a role in reflecting stellar
radiation for reflecting sunlight back
out into space and that also plays a
role in setting the climate state so the
bottom line is we
we're trying to come at this problem
from many different directions and it's
all complicated which is good in the
sense because we have jobs to do this it
was easy so some of the parameters are
the raw sort of biochemical signatures
but other parameters do with just
understanding the the environment the
climate state of a planet and that's a
challenge yes go ahead
so what we're saying and absolute we
have a different approach to this right
so we have many many groups who have
this climate model that was done for the
earth so we have one at the culligan
Institute you've one with several where
we're basically making a huge data cube
if you want
well we actually making our models do
things for longer day lengths for bigger
gravity but the problem that we
encounter of course is that we have no
data sample that you can compare that to
because we don't have an Earth's that
happens to be heavier right we have some
information about an earth that's
younger and we have this amazing
artist's impression that you see behind
us of what these planets that we've
discovered or that astronomers have
discovered could be like some have one
Sun some have two suns the Sun's up
there in man try to model the climate of
the earth and put a second Sun in this
model was never designed to have to
sense because Earth's was never designed
to have to self in a way so we're
getting a lot of insights and the
question really is also if the climate
when could we find the signs of life
even if they exist some climate
conditions will actually make it
impossible for us to spot them and some
climate conditions will make it easier
for us to spot them and with thousands
of planets out there what we're trying
to do is pick the easiest ones to tease
this out and one last point is that when
Caleb and I were talking about the
habitable sound there's no way to say
that outside of the selm there couldn't
be life there could be life on icy moons
for example like your Robo Enceladus but
it would be hidden from our view because
this ice
there would basically keep all the gases
the only thing that we can really see
from far far away hidden from our
telescopes we'd have to go there drill a
hole and check if there fish or anything
else but so this is why this definition
of the Hannibal song just to make sure
it's not where there can be life it's
where we without going there can pick it
up if it exists just a tiny little
interesting piece to that you mentioned
the icy moons and that's absolutely an
essential thing to remember because if
you look at our solar system we have
this picture of this little Oasis world
I think one of those posters talks about
the Oasis earth sitting closer to the
Sun but if for example having liquid
water oceans defines an oasis then
actually the majority liquid water
oceans in our solar system are in the
outer solar system if you add up all the
potential liquid water inside Europa
inside Enceladus inside even Titan and
possibly even Pluto it's about 13 times
the total volume of liquid water on
earth except it's in these dark oceans
these oceans sealed away by icy crusts
so for all we know our solar system is
teeming with more life but it's locked
away in these dark oceans so Sarah we
have the potential with places like Mars
where we might actually be able to get
there someday but I guess I'd like to
ask you know you got the Mars 2020 and
the ExoMars 2020 Rovers that are going
to get a much closer look at the surface
of Mars than we've ever had before so
what should they be looking for and what
do you expect they'll find I'm not
convinced there's life on Mars but but
I've been really intrigued with this
idea that life really needs to take over
an entire planet yeah um and and so if
you look at life on Earth
everything about the Earth's system is
defined by the presence of life in some
sense even like the biogeochemical cycle
so the cycling of elements is controlled
by life and that's something really
fascinating about what humans are doing
now is we're starting to control those
those biogeochemical cycles so if you if
you look at something like
the models that we send Caleb we're
talking about
one of the things I thought really
intriguing hearing about those is we
don't even know how to model earth
without life right and so so I think I
think this idea that that that life
really becomes embedded in a planet is
really fascinating and gets this idea
about back to like thinking about
definitions of life and what we're
actually looking for we think of life as
this this you know chemical phenomena in
a cell as the fundamental unit for life
and so we should be looking for cells on
Mars but that may be too narrow of you
and if you do have this kind of expanded
view and are really looking for more
fundamental basic processes of life it
really opens your horizons for things
that you might look for and so when I
think about looking for life I'm not
really thinking about looking for cells
on a planet or molecules in an
atmosphere I think about looking for an
entirely new sector of physics and that
seems like kind of an unusual way of
thinking about it but but we have some
really amazing mathematical theories of
the world we have quantum mechanics and
general relativity and these amazing
revolutions and our understanding of the
natural world and we don't have any
theories that explain the existence of
life or the properties of life and so I
really think it's it's a new frontier
for us and astrobiology to really
understand those combining observations
and experiments that we're doing here on
earth and really think differently about
what kind of things we're looking for
and so when I think about looking for
life I think about what are the
mathematical structures that we use to
describe life on Earth that we should be
thinking about how to look for those on
other planets and one of the ways that
that has been really incredibly
successful in studying life across all
scales for life on Earth is is this idea
of using networks and so on so probably
everybody in here is part of a social
network right is anybody here a part of
a social network everybody raise your
hands yeah you're in a room with people
so you're in a social network but you're
probably also in a social network online
and you can actually represent networks
mathematically and and they're they're
quite simple mathematical structures
everybody in this room would be
represented as a circle and if you're
friends with each other you'd have a
line between you and you can actually
study the statistics of those kind of
systems and this is really interesting
because if you look at systems like the
camera
street happening in your cells or the
structure of the internet or the
structure of facebook there's a lot of
regularities in the in the way those
networks are structured and and a lot of
that has to do with the way information
is structuring those systems so so if
you think about a social network really
you're not interacting with those people
physically you're interacting with them
through through information technology
or some kind of information exchange and
so what I find intriguing is trying to
actually think about how we can use
insights from complex systems to look
for life on earth in particular maybe
you know Mars atmosphere or atmospheres
of other planets might have some
signatures in the actual system level
organization of the planet and what I
mean by that is you could actually just
like we can represent chemistry so the
way we represent chemistry and your
cells as a network as we say the
molecules interact so they would be the
nodes in the network and if they
participate in a reaction together then
they have a line between them and so you
can represent an atmosphere that way too
it's just chemistry it has the same kind
of mathematical representation and so
some people have done some preliminary
studies where they show Earth's
atmosphere looks more like the chemistry
inside your cells than it does like Mars
or Venus as atmosphere from this network
perspective now that has a lot of work
to be done to confirm that this is
really like a system-level property of
atmospheres of inhabited planets but if
it is it gives us a better window into
thinking about what our biological
systems at a planetary scale how do they
shape planetary scale structure of the
chemistry and how can we actually use
that as a bio signature that's not just
dependent on the particular molecules
participating in those networks but
actually the system level organization
and so one of the ways that that I tend
to think about that why looking at
individual molecules is bad but maybe
looking at system level properties is
good for detecting life is you you're
all made of atoms in this room right but
you wouldn't think of any individual
atom in your body as alive but you as a
whole system level entity are alive so
it clearly has to be an emergent
property of many interacting molecules
and so I think one of the things that we
need to start doing is actually start
using those kind of tools for thinking
about our search for life it gets hard
with exoplanets because you get so
little
so one of the things I find challenging
for the future is to think like how do
we actually extract these kind of
properties from that data but I think
that there are new horizons for thinking
about how we search for life that aren't
just the way that we've been thinking
about it in the past and it really comes
from trying to think more quantifiably
about the search I think that actually
leads Caleb into you know this
consideration for the Fermi paradox and
which can be set you know really with
the question of where is everybody you
know I mean where is everybody and who
should we be looking at you know and you
know this this idea is the answer to the
Drake question zero so maybe I'll just
state what the the Fermi paradox is and
then then we have a little I think we
have a little movie to show so the Fermi
paradox is this idea that if there is
life out there
if life happens reasonably often in our
galaxy for example then he's pretty old
it's at least 10 billion years old and
so following our own trajectory there's
been plenty of time for some species out
there to have come into existence if
it's been lucky or unlucky depending on
your perspective it became intelligent
and technological and decided to try to
go between the stars and the interesting
thing about that is it turns out that
once you start doing that you occupy the
galaxy pretty quickly and so this raises
the question if life is not incredibly
rare or if there isn't something that
prevents it from doing this and where is
everybody why hasn't it it shown up now
of course some people feel it has shown
up but we won't go there I don't if we
have the the little Fermi video ready
yeah so let me explain what this is this
is actually the work of Jonathan Carroll
now I'm back and Adam Frank who I've
been working with and this is a picture
of our galaxy but it's a highly
idealized model of our galaxy what
looking at eternal point of light each
little sphere represents about two and a
half million stars and the colors
correspond to interstellar species
relocating themselves expanding I would
say colonizing but that word has such
negative connotation these days they're
expanding out each color corresponds to
particular technological species now
what you're seeing in this
representation is a pretty active galaxy
it's colorful in the middle things come
and go because there are things like
supernovae that go off and essentially
sterilize big pieces of our galaxy so
civilizations in the middle of our
galaxy kind of like building a house in
Hawaii all right
yeah this looks good I know there's a
volcano and that may be something that
happens in central galaxies were there
many more stars many more supernovae and
other violent events that might actually
sterilize pieces of the galaxy now this
is an exaggerated model the part of the
reason for looking at this question this
way is that things move around in our
galaxy and stars have motion and that
actually encourages the spread of an
interstellar species because you may not
have to have such wonderful rocket ships
to go between stars if the stars
themselves every so often come closer to
each other so that's part of what we
were trying to model it's a very
exaggerated model because in that 40
million years that you just saw passing
we assume that species can travel about
half the speed of light when they decide
to but even if you tuned it down and you
make it much more difficult to travel
between the stars and you make the
occurrence of star Ferenc species much
less frequent use discover that it still
it's pretty easy to fill the galaxy with
life so the bottom line is it reinforces
this big open question of where is
everybody so that's essentially the
Fermi paradox brought up today
both of me okay I'll be contrarian so
the point is like I teach astronomy 101
so I have like undergrad students with
no science major one of the questions
that I asked him when we get to the
Fermi paradox
so Fermi basically decided that his
answer was that the speed of light this
era limit and say you'd have to be
incredibly motivated or have a really
good reason why you'd want to spend so
much of your time
like our closest star after the Sun is
four light years away so if you could go
with 10% of the speed of light it's
still a 40-year trouble that you have to
survive you have to have energy and food
for and you have to have a very good
reason to go right but what I do in my
class when we get to the Fermi paradox
into the Drake Equation I'm saying look
I have this amount of money and we can
go to one planet let's assume the whole
galaxy is teeming with them I have one
planet that is 5000 years older than us
and one planet that's 5000 years younger
and then I pull my class and say which
one should I spend my money on to go and
visit and most of the time to always
except for one person who always wants
to go back in time because they're
scared about something new everyone
wants to go to the further develop on
because they want to know what's going
on and then if you take that I love our
planet I love our species I think the
astronauts are amazing you know let me
say that but we only made it to the moon
with people right we made it with a
rover to Mars was great and to tighten
with a satellite that we land in and so
on but we are really not that
interesting assuming there's lots of
places you could choose from so I think
we just incredibly boring
before that just to say I mean one issue
is you're introducing the factor of
agency and we try to avoid that in our
modeling because we age encima be
organisms are the species oh just a
quick comment so we are boring
probably we're a relatively young planet
and you know if there truly are alien
technological civilizations they could
be you know 50 million years older than
us so we may not know what to look for
but I do think it's interesting though
that you know we do tend to think of
this issue in terms of this model of
galactic expansion it's called the coral
model right where we start in one spa
and then we send out maybe von Neumann
probes which are a eyes or spaceships in
the old-fashioned way and then they send
out their ships and we expand but that's
highly at the prom or '[ __ ] but
intriguingly
we have already started interstellar
missions we have project breakthrough
starshot which in I believe 20 years is
aiming to go to the Alpha Centauri
region and I think the speed that
they're anticipating if things work out
I mean there's issues like space dust
when your the way they do it is that
they're incredibly small there's so
light that they can go very very fast
these little light sail ships but the
point here is if you do want to expand
in this way even we have the resources
to begin to at least examine these other
regions fairly cheaply I mean each ship
is fairly inexpensive of course it takes
a lot of energy to send the ships out
but I think the question here is will
are we being too anthropomorphic when we
think of the Fermi paradox I mean we're
thinking of galactic expansion but these
civilizations that are perhaps 50
million years older than us are thinking
entirely differently than we are so who
knows maybe they have already visited
and
just don't know I hope no reporters call
I mean by our meek intellectual
resources there are dozens of intriguing
responses to the Fermi paradox but
there's been nothing that convinced me
you know either way
well interested in asking CEREC question
about the sort of information approach
to life networks and so on we
automatically kind of think of it as old
life well it's it's tough here but could
it be applied on a much grander scale to
understand something like the Fermi
paradox I hope so so I was first gonna
disagree with all of you because I don't
think we're boring one person on the
panel that doesn't think we're boring I
think we're the most fascinating thing
in the universe it's really crazy that
we're here having this conversation
right now but from the perspective of
the Fermi paradox I mean my resolution
is is very similar to Susan I just I
think we don't know what we're looking
for and if we if we understand life on
Earth better and we do we develop these
kind of quantifiable criteria to answer
your question then we should be able to
identify it and it might be that we
identify it in completely different ways
than we had anticipated previously and
so one of the things that I made this
argument before that that life isn't a
chemical phenomena and I really do think
it's not so when when I say that like
cities are alive I really think cities
are alive and I think computers are
alive and I think AI is is life and so
these are all examples of the same kind
of infer information mattering to the
world re emerging at different scales
and we don't really know how high up in
a hierarchy that goes we know that that
chemistry organized into unicellular
organisms and that those organized into
multicellular organisms and then we had
social systems and then we had cities
and we have technological civilization
that's now globally integrated and now
we're inventing artificial intelligence
and so hi how how many scales are there
to that kind of living process and
hierarchy and so very advanced life
could look entirely different
anything that we could anticipate right
now or life in different media could
look entirely different it doesn't need
to be the kind of chemistry that we have
on earth today so I think what we really
need to understand is what is what life
is and what it's doing before we can
really ask and rule out possibilities a
very short thing I think a completely
agree that we just a little bit to earth
centric right because maybe if we evolve
a little further we actually gonna be
fine with the energy and the resources
we have we gonna actually manage them
right because usually it colonization or
moving out right it's because you're
running out of resources you need
something else
and in addition 75% of all the stars out
there are small red stars who have a
much much longer lifetime than the Sun
so they don't have to go anywhere to
find somewhere else we do and so this is
why I love the astronaut program no
that's before we have about a billion
years on this planet before because the
Sun like every other star gets right -
with time it's just what they do it's
gonna get hotter on the earth so even
without us amplifying the co2 we can
speed the process up but even if we
don't then in about a billion years it's
gonna be way too hot here so we're gonna
lose the surface oceans with all the
models that we're running and so we'd
have to be either a spacefaring species
at that point to go somewhere else to
build hopefully one of these amazing
space station that I keep seeing in the
science fiction movies and I really want
to live on one of those and you could
think about a space station being Paris
one London one New York and I have no
problem I don't need another planet if
that's the case but I think a lot of the
time you know because the Fermi paradox
and the Drake Equation where this
amazing first attempts to quantify the
problem but I think it's also deeply
rooted and our idea that we won't get
our resources sorted out that we will
have to expand to survive and that
everyone does and so I'm very much with
Susan hopefully that if
a 15 million year older civilization or
you know the numbers are staggering they
could be six billion years older than we
are so older than us when the earth was
born it's not even something I can
imagine but I do help I'm a positive or
I'm an optimist for humankind and
civilization I hope we get our energy
and resources sorted and then we
wouldn't have to expand we would go and
find out because we're curious we could
travel but we wouldn't have to colonize
and therefore this whole idea that you
would spread over the whole galaxy to
actually make it yours might not appeal
to us because I think some of us in the
audience right if you see a place where
you'd love to live but you see somebody
else has built a house there I'm not
gonna go and actually push it down and
say no I'm here and I hope as a species
we evolved to that system too and so we
have our amazing planet and Oasis in
space maybe we don't need to occupy
everything else I agree with a lot of
that I mean I think the one thing is
though and this is often an argument I
use when people ask me well why do you
study things like astrobiology and life
and universe because it's the way we're
going to learn about ourselves and I
just wonder where the part of a
motivation for spreading across the
universe is you still looking for
answers about yourself and you may never
be able to find all of those by staying
at home I just just just to put that out
there if we accept that there is life
out there let's talk about whether or
not that life might be intelligent
whatever that means
so what does that mean I think one of
the things that's very interesting about
us as an intelligent civilization is
that we construct theories of our world
and we can and don't like laws and we
can use those to do really interesting
things like launch satellites into space
or people into space and so so so
theories themselves are actually
information about the world and their
information that allows us to do things
and so that's one way that I actually
define intelligence is when you start
having things that that that those
systems actually have knowledge or
information
allows them to generate structures that
wouldn't be possible without having
knowledge there is no possibility that
you would have all those satellites
orbiting our planet unless we had a
technological civilization with
intelligence and knowledge about the
laws of physics so when we're thinking
about looking for intelligent life out
there I think what we need to look for
is things that can't be explained by
physics and chemistry alone but require
additional information in the system to
actually generate those structures now
as I'm saying that I have no idea what
the heck that means but I think that we
need to think about that kind of
perspective in order to really clarify
the questions that we're asking so we're
at this point in the program where we're
gonna transition to part four which is
life in the future we have this idea
that we're gonna make AI alive and is
that an okay to think the thing to think
about so what we're seeing on earth
right now with the development of
artificial intelligence is a revolution
and it's changed all of our lives we're
on the internet we have our smoke
smartphones we'll soon like have very
sophisticated personal assistants I mean
in a blip when you look at the cosmic
scale of things it's a blip we will you
know within a hundred years start
upgrading our own intelligences to where
we may actually be post biological we
could become cyborgs if you will instead
of carrying around a phone it will be in
the head we'll have mobile internet
connections we'll have enhanced working
memories we'll learn languages quickly
because we may just get a new neural
implant it could look like science
fiction well if that's the trend that we
see on earth people have increasingly
started asking what alien civilizations
could be like if life does survive on
other planets past its technological
maturity that is if they don't have
terrible problems like nuclear wars or
you know environmental catastrophes they
may have the opportunity to become
synthetic beings intelligence is
realized in a lot
different ways as people here appreciate
the same sort of neural algorithms could
be run as Sarah knows in a different
substrate we see intelligence systems
that are silicon based for example on
earth so all this suggests to a certain
degree that when we're searching for
intelligent alien civilizations the
little green man or ET model as much as
I like Yoda it's my favorite alien
that's not necessarily what we want to
be looking for when we're looking for
technological civilizations we might be
looking for synthetic intelligences that
are computronium the size of a planet
mmm
there are a lot of moral and ethical
issues to think about here they may not
be conscious and it may not feel like
anything to be them if they're synthetic
we may find out answers to these
questions as we develop our own a eyes
on Earth that's not to say however the
intelligent civilizations are out there
one thing that didn't come up in
response to the Fermi paradox that I
thought I of as incredibly interesting
is the idea of the great filter so
there's this is called the great filter
argument by the economist Robin Hanson
and he suggests essentially that you
know we don't even know how easy it is
to find life I mean to actually get life
kick-started on another planet because
we don't know how really what to say
about the origin of life on Earth so we
actually don't know given all those
exoplanets how many places are actually
inhabited because we don't know how easy
it is for life to get going but suppose
you do have microbial life on these
planets well how difficult is it to get
from microbial to more complex forms of
life and then from there how difficult
is it to get to intelligent life and
then from there how long how possible is
it to survive technology
maturity and we have nuclear war super
intelligent AI all kinds of global
catastrophic risks that our civilization
faces and maybe it's that way for other
civilizations so Hansen suggests there
could be a great filter anywhere at all
from the very beginning from the
inception of life on a planet to highly
intelligent life so I think these are
the kind of issues which are interesting
to think about when it comes to things
like the Fermi paradox and you know
Sarah with the idea of looking for
complex systems and these networks what
would you consider AI to be life based
on based on that yeah I definitely do so
so I I think that the post biological
phase of evolution is really interesting
but people tend to think it's really
different than what we've seen in the
history of life so far but if you adopt
sort of this informational perspective
of life it seems like the natural
consequence of the way life evolves on a
planet that if it is increasingly
building better information processing
systems that that would be an inevitable
outcome and it's not that it's an
unnatural one or that it's a bad one
it's just what happens and so I think I
think that that we tend to be afraid of
these things but I don't I don't think
that we should be afraid of artificial
intelligence I think it's it's just a
part of what we are and who we are and
and in some sense that those systems
will be our progeny in a long-term
future and they may be biologically
integrated they may be entirely
artificial but they are still something
that we created that we will send out
into the universe and so something I
find really intriguing about this
discovery of alien life is is that it
might be very likely that the things
that we discover artificial but also
what's discovering them is artificial
because we don't usually send humans out
into space we're sending machines and
we're probably going to be sending
machine learning algorithms and aio into
space so really when we're talking about
making alien contact it may not even be
biological it's gonna be artificial
systems making contact with other
artificial systems and will they
consider ours alive
[Laughter]
it raises some interesting ethical
questions really interesting yeah maybe
just to inject contrarian so as I'm
sitting here listening to this what I'm
what I'm realizing is you know in a lot
of these discussions to do with things
like the great filter and also the Fermi
paradox and spreading around space there
seems like there's this implicit
assumption that species remain the same
and and you mentioned you know earth in
a billion years when the Sun has gotten
a bit hotter and our planet has this
runaway greenhouse wall day we won't be
there evolution will have taken care of
that evolution itself might be the
filter because we're not static no
matter how much we might imagine
ourselves you know a million years in
the future humans in the future we will
not be the same biological entities that
we are now neither will our machines be
the same machines that they are now
evolution is perhaps the most
unstoppable force in the universe and so
I just wonder you know if we're talking
about life in the future you know it's
going to be totally different than
anything that exists right now I think
we can say that with certainty even as
us we won't be around even despite our
best intentions right we can we can
solve our energy problems we can you
know write records of everything we have
literature and so on you know
biologically I'm not sure it's either
possible or desirable to halt our
biological evolution and it evolution
hat Darwinian evolution happens at
multiple time scales it's happening
right now like that it's also happening
over millions of years and it's very
very difficult to see where it's going
so I think you know part of what's
happening is were kept we're getting to
this point where well humans in the
future we won't be humans anymore
we'll be something else we should be
protecting allows absolutely because the
timescale may be very odd but this may
also have something to say about the
Fermi paradox about the great filter
that it's
actually evolution that that just that
aggressively expanding species it takes
it still ten million years to get
anywhere interesting in the galaxy by
the time it's done that it's not the
same species there is this like
intrinsic need to be the same but like
but the thing that always strikes me is
really interesting is we aren't
physically the same as we were like ten
years ago I mean literally like the
atoms in your body or not the same I'm
not for sure think about as being the
same is is very subjective and so I so I
think I think Caleb's absolutely right
that we are continually evolving systems
and we're systems that where information
is constantly restructuring us so so the
reason that you're still you know a
coherent entity ten years later even
though you don't have the same atoms is
because your body is constantly
rebuilding itself and so an evolution
just does that on a different time scale
it builds new systems from the previous
systems and and that's totally fine so I
think I think our definition of what we
are needs to be expanded and that's one
of the also the reasons that I like this
idea of thinking about life at a
planetary scale because we are all life
on Earth and it's very integrated as you
were describing before we can't really
take out a piece of it and say it's
separate and so when we're thinking
about the evolution of life on this
planet we have to think of that entire
planetary sitting and we are definitely
going to evolve into something else in
the future and probably AI is gonna be
tightly integrated with that we don't
know what that's gonna look like but but
it's not not gonna be us it's still
gonna be the same lineage
I like astrobiologists so much because
meteors so laid back
the next 200 years because you think of
everything when these grand timescales
but I think we have to remember that we
right now have a lot of issues with
emerging technologies that urgently need
to be navigated so that we do press on
and that we can make decisions about how
to design minds if you will so Caleb you
talk about it all being a matter of
evolution in a Darwinian sense but even
Richard Dawkins said recently in a film
that we were both in called super
sapiens when it comes to artificial
intelligence and brain
enhancement it is now the era of
intelligent design we are the designers
which is why I think the idea of being
earthlings is so important if we're
looking at ourselves as as planetary
system it's not just me deciding it's
not just you deciding it's as as this
the inhabitants of this planet we have
to decide how are we going to work
together for that future that I'd like
to think you know my son who's only 15
he's got his life to live and you know
and yeah there's this grander scale of
time but where we all change at all that
happens but I want to know that you know
as human beings we're gonna figure out
how we survive here too I mean this is
another motivation for finding other
life and if we ever got to the point
where we could interrogate maybe
interrogate what mistakes they made you
know there are other stories out there
potentially that could tell us how to do
things and actually make it through this
augmentation period or make it through a
filter you know there may be other
places where it worked and places where
it failed and we could learn from that
too that's a stretch but yeah I think
they call in the beginning after you ask
why we should care for example if we
don't find life out there what what our
reasons would be and I think Caleb just
touched on one of those by finding other
planets like ours out there we'll find
some that are older than us and even if
evolution is different let's say some
will be in a further evolutionary stage
than we are and that is the only way
that allows us the glimpse in our
potential future and the way I usually
talk about this is like for example we
see all older Earth's have a lot of so2
in the atmosphere comes from volcanoes
we can't breathe it
that doesn't mean it will happen to the
earth but it would mean that it would be
intelligent for us to develop a
technology to filter it out just in case
this is something that happens to all
earth and so even if people don't care
about whether we alone in the universe
what's coming
being as informed as we can whether we
become synthetic or not taking as good
care as we can of our own planet I think
it's the imperative that right now we
are guarding this planet and we are
responsible for it I love that as kind
of a closing note because when we think
about exploring further off our planet
finding or not finding what we consider
life to be out there we know from what
we've done already
even in low-earth orbit and as human
beings only getting to the moon so far
that we have learned a lot about
ourselves and about how we do those
things to improve life here on earth I
want to thank all of you for a really
really impressive
[Applause]
you
[Music]